okay this game loves [ __ ] crash it
you know like this it like it's probably
like the if you want to have a game that
crashes your computer there's probably
the best games app just because it's
very versatile like you know okay oh oh
my god yeah [ __ ] okay um let's see
where we gotta go let's look at this
mission right here you know Sam
my peeps
I can't body right now is redoing
through a sports car
okay okay okay we're doing I got no
crash and so far I think this game is
like to give a make in them it's pretty
funny thing how it just turns off okay
because you look at the radar just like
how many gangs that are much like real
life you know
chase ass oh do you see that the guy
took it [ __ ] get out of the cards
[ __ ] up like that again let's hear
getting close to getting close
well you actually see like the border of
the loading car like people really like
put in chairs and stuff it's crazy and I
got this writing real quick you know
sometimes she's got a taste to GPS like
where to go you know
ok yeah miss Lego oh it's actual main
house ok i gotcha
oh oh I almost hit that cop Jesus okay
yep philly a respek bar I thought I
could do that one okay I out see you
don't see any other animals now not sure
I forget and i can buy some [ __ ] i gue
race loved it hope I need this car that
phrase though
who is in cardiff that's getting more
which is all right to this one
let's just go do another mission
basically the first one we see you know
side by this place can i do that let's
shake it let's check it Jesus glitching
like crazy great what is it a bouncer oh
yeah it's for sale okay okay so why this
was over here too yes not for sale
access rob this place is okay
and okay gotta get the hell out of here
that [ __ ] he's chasing an take a [ __ ]
Oh me buy this place
I could get that Brown right here yes
but oh
okay okay it really it's so much money
directed a mistake us make it get good I
don't get respect that yeah well let's
just see what else there is
okay okay
Jesus
look this is just turning a bad you know
like
ooh that's what's great Jesus
you
let's see
I think is a great thing ok dad across
that bridge from out here it is
just feel like the good side of town
oh is that
I wonder if everyone's getting out of
cups away because Oh cop
there's no waking with that run over
some of the same vehicle that's weird
oh Jesus Jesus before i do i liked i
fell respect bar Jesus um let's see here
how I can be this guy music hot bar that
looks so fast okay here we go here we go
where is it oh sorry okay here we go
three two one
Jesus it might in a race oh just a time
to beat it ok
Jesus
that's you like insane okay oh god I'm I
am halfway done this is bad this is bad
I'm not gonna make it
you
do it may make it
oh my god i got the gold medal ok
history dope
okay i finally got enough of that Rana
mission okay we're going back we're
going back save this can i can again
what is that like a fence second year I
got here yet
this is a crazy fast Jesus
you
I can
mm-hmm strada know what love hit these
things
I get back at the neighborhood back of
the neighborhood
and this car is not going to make it and
I mean it
yeah that I where's Johnny oh I sent him
out to the store you should be bet
that's our new house guess baby hmm this
[ __ ] riding around our turf that's
something you want to tell me okay go to
have oh Jesus that wasn't very nice
sorry about that why the [ __ ] are you
here whatever you do to me is nothing
here to work have a Polish Jew so white
guys my name is Japanese the oil born no
[ __ ] why is he coming I'll die before I
tell you yep wash up it better oh [ __ ]
some ass mother well she's a father a
showgirl fuji the [ __ ] run in the
road okay so who cares this guy's a
[ __ ] boogeyman when i was in jail I
would listen to some of the Ronin talk
about what this guy did in Japan it's
not pretty you think he's all talk I
don't know but I'm looking forward to
find it out hey you cool taking out
those [ __ ] by yourself I gotta clean
up around the house of yes I'll get us
I'll go on to do this
ok ok ok guess yeah
let's do this okay oh this is not going
well this is not going well okay huh
Jesus this is not go up this is getting
freaky okay okay go bother someone else
ok ok ok ok sir you you know this is
what we need to begin with him how you
gonna stop a car if you know like
make a hairy guy a guy
this is what I'm talking about
yes there he is
00
oh yeah
mr. iris what I know I where is a his
County Spelling
yeah how's AZ Jesus Dane don't worry
I'll get the money back you're missing
the point show go the money was insured
I'm more concerned about you what Walter
and the Ronin have had a very healthy
relationship in the past but lately well
when I pay protection money I expect
some [ __ ] protection watch yourself
Vogel the Saints are a concern show go
not for long why is that I've got my
best man working on that now he'll lose
a recycle with the five moshi moshi what
is it true don't worry I'll take care of
it like always it was malice sister I
frog yeah okay
ok let's get this dead